hamel tu fais un petit tour de magie à
nous faire avancer les huit hommes et
quatre tirs dow jones exactement
bonsoir à tous d'abord bonsoir et merci
à dinan chanter chanter ça va acheter
nord c'est gentil
j'arrive d'une ce qu'on va faire on va
voyager ensemble ok ouais super j'ai un
doute apporter c'est un jeu quartier
tout neuf
vraiment oui fermé vers le haut pharma
sur le côté fermé vers le bas je peux
donner à examiner il permet comme on n'a
pas trop le temps tout d'abord confiance
ok mais ramé web ou fait absolument
est ce qu'on va faire on veut tous nous
sommes en quelque sorte c'est ado
vraiment vraiment très la 3do va le
prêter
hop je vais te confier l'étude et si
j'apporte un jeu de cartes avec issus
des jo car toutes les cartes qui sont
classés dans l'ordre
las le 2 le 3 le 4e 5e 6e 7e 8e 9e 10
valait dames - c'est un peu les cartes
ok vraiment ce qu'on va faire je vais te
demander d'enlever les terres
publicitaire que de mélanger
oui les tartes s'il te plaît gérad sud
waka raymond sim trop d'avocats
d'affaires du losail au poker mais à mon
avis elle a peur elle est là elle a
récupéré le blouson de quelqu'un qui
n'est pas de ce lac d'une heure donc ce
qu'on voit c'est vraiment toutes les
cartes vraiment où toutes différentes
mais c'est très mal mélanger le 2 mai 3e
date le 5
tout ça pour faire ça vraiment vraiment
vraiment toute la terre tout différent
gérald dudouet
je parle anglais ou pas dit ok très bien
faudra emballer nom en anglais veut
chercher le coca light
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faudra me dire stop on en décidera ok
ok très bien ce que je vais faire je
vais faire passer les cartes et tu vas
me dire stop quand tu veux d'accord ok
tu tapes avant la fin parce qu'après on
recommence
tapez pas prendre assez sympa tu la
regardes oui c'est fait et je vais te
demander de faire une grosse île nature
en plein milieu s'il te plaît ok voilà
très bien en plein milieu ok ça fait
très bien il reste un peu de postes sur
la tarte way très bien ce que tu peux
maintenant numéro un numéro de portable
si madame arriva lequel celui de mathieu
non ouais tu matches pourquoi pas ok les
gars nous terme le toit non c'est fait
ouais très bien voilà on va remettre
juste la carte issue parfait on va
montrer rapidement la caméra juste comme
ça on l'a bien vu
oui oui oui parfait est ce qu'on va
faire va tarder attire dans le milieu du
poker comme ceux-ci dame et du gmail est
ce que je vais faire je vais le nom de
code ce sujet et je veux couper le
patron du génial géraldine à ce que ça
serait impressionnant si je claque des
doigts la seule carte qui remonte sur la
tartine et ça serait impressionnant par
serait très intéressé au regard du tissu
parfait il ya une tarte sociale qui
remonte à ronald à j'ai dit que ce sera
impressionnant j'ai pas déjà le faire et
son coup droit très fin et qu'on fera
tout doucement sur le pâtis tapis en
principe
[Applaudissements]
on a marqué ce numéro c'est numéro 2 de
mathieu a deux matches aux 80 ne montre
pas non je connais c'est pas le tiens
c'est pas le servathon a su cultiver des
menus aux marqueurs ouais mais je sais
que géraldine c'est dire aux 6 12
oui enfin c'est tout vainqueur ce qu'on
va faire on va continuer voire commencer
donc je vais prendre ici voilà parfait
on va prendre et si le sac de terreau
szczecin et signatures pour vivre aimer
signature quand même regarder bien c'est
un paraphe tout doucement j'arrive à
prendre at heart on va mettre dans le
milieu du papier mais simplement faisant
juste sa carrière mohammed kamel a
regardé la magie selon gainey ce qu'on
va faire exceptionnellement comme sommes
sûreté pmp je vous ai je vais vous
expliquer le tour ça voudrait oui mais
gardant secret passé tour dans
l'émission puisqu'il savait même pas
lui-même comme une hérésie nous ce qu'on
va faire pour que tout le monde puisse
bien voir je vais prendre le sac de
terreau dessinée et je vais bombe est là
car je vais l'attendre comme ça à partir
de maintenant on va facilement la suivre
donc jusqu'ici tout va bien
vraiment voilà on va se mettre juste là
parfait donc regarder bien je me retire
d'un milieu du paquet et pour l'avoir
monté suffit simplement de faire sa une
je suis partout luz mans bat adams est
un peu retourné la terre tu peux
retourner mais là on est à 1 cm les mois
c'est un prime en fait pas produite si
on va leur montrer la caméra voilà
side-cars ou ce que je fais jamais de la
terre dans le milieu du paquet et
géraldine je peux avoir dès demain s'il
s'appelait balladur fermer ta main
complètement sur pattes et complètement
génial pareil jean-michel contre
l'occasion de toucher géraldine voilà
voilà parfait comme ceux ci génèrent de
plus en plus à vos pieds à votre âme et
ckoi internautes scènes de chaos
non merci savoir cyril assez joker parce
que je t'ai remplace l'importateur vous
allez voir très rapidement
géraldine tout à l'heure je l'avais dit
qu'on allait voyager dans le temps oui
et je vois pas croire simplement
claquant des dents dans monte trois
mi-temps la regarder chanter ça luc
hamel
je suis content de te voir toi pareil ça
va pas faire la même chose avec isabelle
morini-bosc chante et ça revient ça va
merci d'amener par croire syrie dont on
est vraiment remonter dans le temps et
se rendait à remonter dans le temps tu
te souviens tu imagines au début du tout
j'avais un père qui était tout neuf qui
était fermé et était scellé si on claque
des doigts par contre se désole c'est la
fin du cube juste ici s'en faut
tu prends de tout doucement et c'est là
où vos plans non
[Applaudissements]
la recette
emma regarde bien on va perdurer le
docteur vraiment j'étais vraiment tous
les sens et son look tout doucement
comme ceci vous n'êtes pas croire à la
tarte fine aux idées larges voilà
parfait ici dans l'étude ici un jeu car
avec comme le calleur le joker tout cas
car s'ils sont là ce temps là est le 2
le 3 les tacles et les 7 8 9 10 as 2 3
chat en version des faits tout doucement
toutes les cartes sont différents dans
l'ordre est souvent la seule carte
[Applaudissements]